you say cyrus et bienvenue dans ce coup
de fil 6 qui reprend une forme à peu
près normale et oui je suis de nouveau
dans ma chambre
enfin pensez que je suis dans ma chambre
parce que vous la voyez
mais regardez si je fais ça on voit que
c'est un fond vert
est-ce que je ne serai pas depuis le
début dans un autre endroit c'est ce que
des cartes seraient demandées et sa
réponse est le co quito ergosum je pense
donc je suis ça vous est forcément déjà
arrivé de faire des rêves si réel qu'à
votre réveil genre pendant quelques
secondes vous y croyez encore un peu
comme à inception le héros ne sais pas
si c'est dans un rêve ou dans la réalité
tellement les deux peuvent être
semblable sur ça d'ailleurs qu'il a un
objet qui va lui dire s'il est dans l'un
ou dans l'autre las vegas il se dit
[ __ ] si ça se trouve je suis
actuellement dans un rêve
en fait il se dit que c'est sens donc le
goût le toucher l'odorat la vue l'ouïe
peuvent le tromper ouais tu t'appelles
oui oui je suis désolé mec je parlais
des sens ak d'état bref les sens peuvent
nous tromper comme avec les mirages par
exemple r c'est pour ça qu'on ne juge
pas un objet qu'avec nos sens qu'au nom
à part ce tir par exemple c'est
l'exemple de descartes bas le morceau de
cire qui est dur et froid et que
j'approche au fur et à mesure du feu et
qui devient chaud et mou c'est le même
pourtant mes sens le perçoivent
différemment
donc je ne juge pas un objet que par mes
sens parce que mes sens peuvent se
tromper
ouais vas pas me faire croire qu'à des
objets qui l'a pas bien senti
sans se douter de ce que c'était façon
c'est une histoire d'amour d'écarter les
fesses
après que ce soit dans un rêve dans la
réalité les sommets d'un triangle sont
toujours au nombre de trois le rouge est
toujours rouge donc il faut étendre le
doute aux idées simples et mathématiques
du coût des cartes va imaginer ce qui va
appeler un malin génie qui va être là
donc une force supérieure qui va être là
pour le tromper tout le temps donc vu
qu'il peut pas prouver que malin génie
n'existe pas il va faire comme si le
malin génie existait et le tromper tout
temps du coup des cartes il va rentrer
dans un doute qu'on appelle doute
méthodique et le mec va douter de tout
genre vraiment de tout bonsoir bonsoir
mais le plus bas sur quoi pour dire
bonsoir tu te bases sur le soleil qui
n'est plus là et donc c'est forcément le
soir ou bien ta montre qui pourrait dé
régler sans doute méthodique il le fait
car il veut reconstruire le savoir sur
des fondements dont il est absolument
sûr et vous trouvez une certitude
puissant le mec est bon on va faire
comme lui imaginez que vous n'avez plus
de toucher le goût l'odorat de vue et
même douilles
[Musique]
bon le son je vais quand même le maître
sinon on va se faire chier et bien là
qu'est ce qui nous apparaît stop tu es
en train de faire quoi là tu es en train
de penser
oui c'est normal je pense tout le temps
non non c'est important c'est important
parce que si tu penses
si tu penses ya un sujet à l'action ce
sujet c'est toi ce que ça implique secte
égayer ce mec
et ouais c'est ça la première vérité mon
cas c'est que tu es là ouais ouais tu la
sens la grosse intelligence de descartes
tu me l'as en piste j'ai douté un moment
à moi j'ai résisté plus [ __ ]
heureusement j'existe je pense donc je
suis le malin génie renforce l'idée de
cocteau parce que si le malin génie me
trompe et moi ça voudrait dire qu'il
faut que j'existe pour qu ils nous
trompent
et ouais mon garde dans le je pense donc
je suis attention par contre donc vous a
été compris comme une déduction
en fait c'est plus une intuition du coup
après l'avoir sorti à la base en 1637
dans le discours de la méthode
il ressort plus tard mais en dix ans
ergo cogito virgules rko soum si vous
dire je pense j'existe ou plus pour
marquer le pont de de l'intuition et oui
je parle n'attendent d'ailleurs ce mec
ne sait pas que de la philo c'est aussi
une grosse brute en maths et en physique
tellement une brusque que maintenant sa
ville de naissance s'appelle des cartes
ça s'appelait la haye ça s'appelle des
cartes donc jean jaurès avec ses petites
rues la droite à gauche [ __ ] nul en
tout cas j'espère que le cookie taux de
descartes est maintenant plus car pour
vous rendez vous sur la page facebook
sur le twitter abonnez vous pour louper
aucun épisode du coup de fil et moi je
vous dis garder